I dreamt we had a kid so real we named
him after your eccentric uncle what was
his name
Morgan Morgan so you woke up in not
ready we were expecting yes now please
maybe we don't even have a wedding date
yet
you set argost 27 that's the decoy date
because this media circus that's going
on is driving me crazy
okay this is me on edge I'm sorry
because I'm trying to keep all the
pictures out of the paper and off the
internet so your weddings not ruined no
one's working harder than remember that
kid from TMZ the you had me trade paint
with on the FDR Drive well I got a case
against me now that's my fault
yeah it's your fault lose some hat blue
some half like the godfathers really
funny now I gotta go to court that's why
when you get out of the cart and just
dressed just like Bert I see you Bert
Bert you son of a tell me a
breakdown there we got a girlfriend you
know anyone anyone come to mind hey
everybody it's Charlie so big news you
may have seen this morning they just
confirmed the future of the Iron Man
characters after Avengers endgame so we
got to break it down there's a new round
of that Amazon giveaway all you have to
do to enter is be a subscriber and leave
your favorite Iron Man moment from the
MCU on the video the really cool thing
about this is it it also confirms what's
going on during the Spider Man far from
home trailer at the beginning when we
see happy show up with that giant check
with Pepper Potts name on it I know
there's a lot of questions about what's
gonna happen to Iron Man but one of the
Iron Man actors confirm what's happening
with the characters going forward after
Avengers in game during Marvel phase 4
this sort of tangentially also backdoor
confirms what's happening with some of
the other characters because it is the
end of a lot of the big a-list original
phase 1 Avengers contracts some of them
will be reciting we already found out
that Chris Hemsworth Thor wants to
continue on and do more movies but the
really big person who has said that he's
basically out effectively in a couple
big interviews in the last year is Chris
Evans so I'll explain like this all ties
together because of a recent interview
so it's actually pretty cool but what
happened this morning is that everyone
was reporting on Pepper Potts Gwyneth
Paltrow saying that she was not
resigning a new contract after Avengers
end game she's like I'm out this is what
her quote reads she says I'm a
old to be in a suit and she's talking
about Iron Man suits like the big actual
metal suits and all that at this point
she's 46 in real life right now which
technically isn't that old but she does
look quite a bit older than when she was
in that first Iron Man movie she says I
feel very lucky I did it because I
actually got talked into it talking
about the first Iron Man movie like she
wasn't sure whether or not she was gonna
join the franchise when Jon Favreau was
making that first one she says I was
friends with Jon Favreau it was such a
wonderful experience making the first
Iron Man and then to watch how important
it has become to fans she also says that
she never expected to be asked back to
do any more movies after that like it
was just that one movie she's like okay
I'll try this out because she had mostly
been doing smaller character based films
in Oscar bait like Shakespeare and love
like that was the big film that she was
known for before Iron Man but because
people were like wait a minute is she
out does that mean that she dies no she
actually goes on to say I feel honored
to be a part of something that people
are so passionate about of course if
they said can you come back for a day
for like a cameo I'll always be there if
they need me so that confirms that
Pepper Potts survives the end of
Avengers endgame she's alive at the
beginning of Spider Man far from home to
authorize this charity payment and put
her name on it to give too happy so the
Spider Man can help rebuild the New York
City homes destroyed in the Avengers
final battle with a nose during Avengers
end game so just to be clear what's
happening at the beginning of Spider Man
far from home is that Spider Man himself
is running PR for the Avengers sort of
handing the giant charity check to them
via Pepper Potts an Iron Man the reason
why Pepper Potts name is on it is
because she's been CEO of Stark
Industries
ever since I think it was Iron Man 2
when she effectively took the title so
she'd be the one to authorize all those
payments that's why Iron Man's name
isn't on it but also the back door
reason because they want to keep fans in
the dark as much as possible about what
happens to Iron Man during phase 4
because the Pepper Potts is a big
character Iron Man is like the biggest
character he's the granddaddy of the
Marvel Cinematic Universe at this point
of course as you go without saying that
happy hogan goes into Marvel phase 4
after endgame completely unscathed
because he looks happy enough here to
flirt with Aunt May much to the chagrin
of spider-man here wait a minute what
just happened but here's why I think
that Iron Man survives the end of
Avengers endgame but his role in the MCU
changes
so much that Robert Downey jr. isn't
around as much pitoni stark Iron Man are
still very visible front and center in
all the movies at least the relevant
movies like The Avengers films and the
spider-man films just because he's so
linked to that character there been a
couple interviews and the things the
actors have said all the foreshadowing
that they're doing about a big Avenger
maybe dying or going away permanently in
Avengers endgame is mostly focused on
Captain America Chris Evans if he didn't
see it last year when infinity war was
happening and they were doing all this
press he was also doing a play that's
why he had this weird-looking mustache
very different looking Chris Evans
during the interview that he gave four
that he effectively said that he was
done in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
after avengers endgame now he wasn't a
hundred percent confirming that he was
going to die but definitely confirmation
at least that he'd be pulling a Gwyneth
Paltrow and not reciting a new contract
there was also a convention appearance a
little while ago last year where he
talked about his last day on set that
had this very final tone to it air of
finality like this is the end of my time
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe so
here's the clip of him talking about
that I don't know I you don't want to
give anything away and and I should
clarify that you know I I know I did
tweet something that made a lot of
people think that it was in some way
spoiler and I just I should clarify that
regardless regardless of how Avengers
four ends I would have tweeted the exact
same thing you know it really was you
know that last day of filming was a very
emotional day and it was the culmination
of almost 10 years of filming and 22
movies this unbelievable tapestry and
you know you you you feel a lot more
emotions and I think even I thought I'd
feel and I felt it was appropriate to
share the gratitude I know it had a
ripple effect but I am neither
confirming or denying anything and to
that end
I I think anything I would any sort of
label I would give the fourth Avenger
would would give away too much and so
after that interview came out a lot of
people especially the Russos try to sort
of contextualize what he was meaning by
that so he's not saying that he's dead
but definitely that there's an air of
finality about his performance during
avengers endgame like you're never gonna
see Captain America Chris Evans like
this in the MCU again that doesn't mean
that he'll never come back because
remember it's a comic book universe
secret wars other really crazy big
Avengers crossover films multiverse
films secret invasion Scrolls
impersonating Captain America there are
a million ways that they could bring him
back in the movies Anthony Russo also
recently said that Chris Evans was not
done in the MCU and I think he's not
being completely honest but listen to
the way he talks about it I mean you
know I think it was more emotional for
him than us only because you know he's
not done yet so yeah and and I won't
explain what that means but the audience
will soon understand what I'm talking
what I think he means when he says that
like he says how fans will understand
why Chris Evans isn't totally done in
the MCU once they see Avengers endgame
is it means that he'll probably come
back for cameos and less strenuous
scenes like Gwyneth Paltrow's Pepper
Potts like I'm not gonna do another
really big thumb but I will totally come
back for a day for a really quick scene
so we're talking like the funny promos
during spider-man homecoming flashbacks
in other movies and the potential to
return in movies that are set during the
past when he was still alive the Black
Widow movie is a really good example of
that that takes place before the events
of her first appearance inside the MCU
during Iron Man 2
here's the thing though there's also a
report that Disney and Kevin Feige have
offered Chris Evans a deal like a
contract in real life to direct some of
the new Marvel Avengers spin-off TV
shows that they're making for the Disney
streaming service like they're doing the
Winter Soldier Falcon show they offer
Chris Evans a directing job on that
Chris Evans is primary reason for
leaving the MCU is that he wants to work
on his smaller indie films that he's
known for doing when he's not doing big
blockbusters he does want to be a
director himself so call that the Ben
Affleck type of contract where the
studio says we'll help finance and
release your little indie movies that
you want to make by yourself
if you also want to continue being part
of our big system in some way even if
it's only behind the camera or for an
occasional cameo what about Iron Man
though what's gonna happen to him this
is the reason why I think that he's
going to survive is one because you have
to have a balance of downer moments and
really happy moments at the end of
Avengers end game because it's the
bookend for all these first 22 films so
if Captain America is gonna be the
downer ending like we're either laying
him to rest because he's died or he's
you know lost to the aether in some way
or trapped in the soul gem you need to
have a happy moment to balance that out
in iron man's wedding to Pepper Potts
can be that happy moment the deleted
scene of Iron Man a Pepper Potts from
infinity war says it all there's so much
for shadowing in that shirts in your
closet our wedding date I had a dream
that was so real that we had a kid and
we named him after your eccentric uncle
so that's why I think that Iron Man
lives and semi retires to be with Pepper
Potts and effectively raised their
eventual child however that's going to
manifest even though that's a big break
from comic book Canon because in most
versions of the comics Iron Man is a
confirmed bachelor for life regardless
of the relationships that he has here
and there there's even a future timeline
where he becomes sorcerer supreme and
he's a much wiser more balanced version
of Tony Stark
but he's still a confirmed bachelor he
has no children I think the reason why
the MCU is pushing them having a kids so
hard is just because it's a more
traditional narrative for characters
like this like people want that happy
ending so they have to find a way to
give it to them while also still pulling
the rug out from under you by getting
rid of Captain America I'm fairly
ambivalent about the Pepper Potts
character you know stays or leaves I
don't really care that much so if she
comes back for a really cool cameo in
the future spider-man movie or something
like that I'll be totally fine with it
in terms of Iron Man as long as these
shows up for at least a little bit in
the future Avengers movies I will be
totally happy even if it's only for a
moment or to give them some help or some
technology or if it's even just a
voicemail to spider-man to give him a
little bit of a pep talk because he's
taking all this additional
responsibility on his shoulders during
spider-man far from home there are a lot
of ways to have scenes involving Robert
Downey jr. without Tony Stark Iron Man
having to be on screen in a full-blown
Iron Man suit so let me know in the
comments what do you think happens to
iron man after avengers endgame in going
into phase four how do they continue to
use him even if Robert Downey jr. isn't
around quite as much they're supposed to
be a couple more trailers this week so
whatever ends up dropping I will totally
make videos for it leave your requests
in the comments below click here for all
my Avengers endgame videos and click
here for my brand-new Shazam trailer
video thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight
[Music]